de los seis años del mandato
presidencial mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador ya cumplió un tercio
elegido con más de 18 millones de votos
de ventaja y en el tercer intento
anb lo fomentó muchas expectativas ahora
que venía para acá
[Aplausos]
un joven en bicicleta
y me dijo tú no tienes derecho a fallar
nos
viajando en aerolíneas comerciales
exigiendo excusas a españa por la
colonia acercándose a líderes
sudamericanos de izquierda como nicolás
maduro la personalidad del presidente
mexicano contrasta con la de su
predecesor enrique peña nieto- en dos
años enfrentó la crisis migratoria hacia
eeuu en colaboración con el presidente
de donald trump la frontera se quedó
cerrada para muchos también firmó un
acuerdo de libre comercio con canadá y
eeuu el tlcan 2.0 bautizado tm
permitiendo mayor negocio con sus
vecinos el ex alcalde de ciudad de
méxico tiene detractores que marcharon
en varias ocasiones a lo largo de esos
dos años
calificándole de comunista y el pánico
que me da que terminan siendo como
venezuela desde el inicio de 2020 y la
pandemia está en el punto de mira su
gestión del coronavirus
para el 23 de noviembre el número de
muertes se ha duplicado de 2000 a
alrededor de 4000 profesas doble
computados en el portal centro
creo que esto demuestra que méxico está
en mal estado
méxico es un bache con más de 100.000
muertes de kobe méxico es el cuarto país
más impactado como motivo de esperanza
la vacuna de astrazéneca se producirá en
parte en territorio mexicano